لا، لا يمكننا أن نتحدث عن
الإيمان الفلسطيني بسرعة كبيرة لأنه لا يشبه
أي شيء رأيته من قبل
[موسيقى] لقد
بدأت للتو في قراءة
القرآن بدافع
الفضول والآن أنا
مدمن مخدرات
[موسيقى] لقد
رأيتها حرفيًا  مقاطع فيديو
لأشخاص فقدوا كل شيء حتى
أطفالهم وهم يحملون
أطفالهم الموتى بين أذرعهم وما
زالوا يشكرون الله حرفيًا، لقد بدأت في
قراءتها لأنني كنت أشعر بالفضول
بشأن ما هو هذا الإيمان الذي
يمتلكه الشعب الفلسطيني، إنه شيء
عميق جدًا وهكذا  عميق لدرجة
أنني انجذبت للتو
لمعرفة المزيد عن الإسلام، صدمت في
أعماقي من الإيمان الذي لا
يملكه الفلسطينيون فحسب، بل الشعب المسلم أيضًا
[موسيقى]
يا
الله [
موسيقى]
محمد لقد نشأت وولدت في
عائلة رائعة جدًا
ولدت ونشأت
كاثوليكية وأنا أول فرد في
عائلتي يعود إلى
الإسلام